You're in a class,
it's near the beginning of the semester.
You write an exam or you handed in an
essay and you don't get the mark that
you desired.
Okay,
so what are your options?
One option would be,
so you've hit an anomaly.
Things didn't happen the way you wanted
them to happen and so maybe you say,
Geez,
that was a boring and stupid class.
Anyways,
this gives me an excuse to get out and
so that's not such a negative thing or
you think,
oh well I really better buckle down and
study and you just started to stay in
the class.
So basically what you've done is
maintained your framework.
I'm going to work through this class,
but you're,
you're,
you've decided to modify some of the sub
routines that make up that frame.
You say,
well I should study more next time or I
have to prioritize this class compared
to other classes.
So it's a micro alteration within the
overarching framework.
But another thing you can do is say to
hell with the class.
I just won't.
I'll just drop it.
And so the advantage to that is problem
gone.
The disadvantages,
well now you have a different problem
which is,
okay,
fine,
you drop the class,
do you have another class that you can
replace it with?
Is that a good way of dealing with micro
failure,
you know,
to move up a level of analysis and throw
throughout the whole frame because you
could also say,
well maybe I should just drop out of
university and maybe I should go hang
myself.
You know,
that's.
Well,
it's the same line of logic.
It's just taken up to a higher degree of
abstraction and so generally speaking
you don't want to solve a problem by
moving up a level in wiping out the
frame within which the problem was
experienced.
Do you want to do that carefully?
Because in principle,
the frame that you were working within
had already.
You'd already assigned value to it and
worked at it.
You've already invested in it.
It's a big sacrifice to blow out the
whole frame.
Now sometimes you can do it.
So anyways,
what happens is,
well,
you get the bad grade and you're upset
about it,
and so you've been plunged from your
happy,
satiated state.
Let's say into a state of relative chaos
and the chaos is,
oh,
I hit an obstacle,
I didn't expect it and now I don't know
what to do,
and so what does it mean to not know
what to do?
Well,
it can mean I need to study harder.
It can mean I should drop this course.
It can mean I should major in a
different subject.
I mean maybe I shouldn't be in
university.
It could mean maybe my future plans have
been formulated badly.
It can mean my future plans had been
formulated badly because I don't
understand myself very well and I've
been telling lies about my past.
Right?
The thing can really expand on you and
that's what the chaotic domain is.
That's the real manifestation of those
things that you had considered
irrelevant,
right?
Because when you go to pick up the exam,
you've got your identity as a competent
student intact.
You're not questioning whether you
should be in the course or whether you
should be in that major or whether you
should be in university.
None of that.
That's all in the implicitly accepted
category and as soon as the anomalous
event emerges,
all of those things that you had
rendered axiomatic start to become
questionable and that's like the shark
coming up out,
coming up from the depths to pull you
down and that's the classic way of
representing that and symbolizing it.
That's Jonah and the whale for example,
so it's something is manifested itself
from the deep unknown and pulls you
under like an alligator at a,
at a waterhole,
which is I'm sure one of the sources
from which we derived that particular
kind of mythological representation
because you could imagine that when we
were on the velt after living on trees,
we had to go down to the dam water holes
and you've.
You've watched enough nature programs to
know what a denial crocodile can do to a
water buffalo.
It's not pretty.
And so to go down to the water,
the chaotic water and the source of all
life as well,
right,
is to risk an encounter with the
terrible thing that lurks in the depths.
And so we use that as a central metaphor
for,
for mapping the sorts of things that
happened,
happened to us in a much more abstract
space.
And you know that because one of the
things you're going to do,
let's say that the,
the,
the professor,
there's a professor obviously who gave
you the bad grade,
okay?
So one logical presupposition is that
you're in some sense insufficient in
relationship to the course.
But another logical and instantaneous
categorization is to throw that person
into the category of malevolent
Predator.
And you'll do that by becoming upset and
cursing the person in your imagination.